dans les rues de strasbourg maintenant
la pluie n'a pas découragé les
retardataires ce dimanche on a fait ses
derniers achats de noël avec une
prédilection pour les produits
traditionnels du terroir alsacien
reportage olivier pensait sylvain
gauthier accessoires obligé des courses
de noël cette année le par à tous
mais le mauvais temps n'aura pas
découragé touristes et habitués
aujourd'hui à strasbourg on se pressait
en famille autour des étals exercice de
style obligé la composition du menu de
réveillon
et parfois il vaut mieux être deux eglin
c'est ce qu'il faudrait choisir delà de
la saucisse à tartiner truffé et puis il
y à des saucisses de gendron aux
pistaches il ya que n'est pas que des
bonnes choses évidemment
et ne comptez pas sur jean-marc maîtres
bouchers pour vous dire le contraire
d'ailleurs pour lui noël est avant tout
l'occasion de faire démonstration de son
savoir faire et aujourd'hui avec ses
pets sa rivale ruiz un peu notre métier
c'est un peu le traditionnel qui revient
sur le marché je sais très bien et pour
accompagner chapeaux et autres foulards
deux parties préparé par jean-marc un
petit tour chez un caviste avisait et
c'est le sans faute
assurez vous allez pouvoir servir
effectivement de nombreuses volaille
avec par exemple une appellation à
laquelle je pense c'est des volnay ou
des volnay premier cru vous allez avoir
de très très beaux accords mais pour sa
consommation personnelle et parce que
noël rime avec heures supplémentaires
notre marchand de vin nous livre son
petit secret il faut prendre des
vitamines il faut
nous on s'entretient en buvant de temps
en temps une grande bouteille de
champagne qu'ils consomment à plusieurs
et avec modération cela va sans dire